المترجم: Sharaf Alkibsi
المدقّق: Tasneem Halawani
في الاول حاقول ما فيش حاجة أسمها مستحيل
مادام في التحدي وثقة بالنفس وتوكل على الله
أكيد كل واحد منا بيقدر يحقق أحلام وطموحاته
مهما كانت حجمها والأهم من هذا
أن يكون لنا دور في تنمية وطننا ومجتمعنا.
أنا فاطمة بن جلال من محافظة مأرب،
الأغلب سيتغرب كيف من مأرب ولهجتي مصرية،
أنا والدي شيخ من مأرب أتزوج
واحده مصرية التي هي أمي
لكن من بداية طفولتي أمي تركت مأرب
وقررت العيش بصنعاء
و كوّنت لي بيئة خاصة من شان
أقّدر أكمل تعليمي هنا
بالفعل قدرت أكمّل تعليمي الجامعي
وحصلت على بكالوريوس أعلام
قسم أذاعة وتلفزيون.
وبهذا كنت أعتبر أول بنت من قبيله عبيده
تكمل تعليمها الجامعي.
(تصفيق)
وكذلك أول مخرجة والوحيدة
التي من محافظة مأرب،
(تصفيق)
طبعا بعد ما خلصت الجامعة جلست في البيت
لكن ليس بمزاجي و انما لعدم
وجود وظائف للشباب او دعم لهم
وكذلك عدم اقتناع بعض أفراد أسراتي بالعمل
لكني صممت و أصريت أنني
لازم أعمل حاجه مميزة
و قلت الذي يحصل يحصل
و لازم أرجع مارب
لكن من خلال مجالي
و فعلاً رجعت
خصوصا أن الفترة الأخيرة اتُهمت مأرب
وبالأخص قبيلة عبيده أنها داعم للإرهاب
وأن أبناءها يقومون بأعمال تخريبية
مثل تخريب أبراج الكهرباء
وأنابيب النفط،
فقررت أن أدعم قبيلتي ومأرب داخل وطني
وأدعم وطني خارج اليمن
فقمت بإنتاج واخراج فيلم وثائقي
عن شخص مبدع ومخترع
كان له دور في تنمية قدرات الجيش اليمني
وحمايته من العدو في الميدان،
فحسن بن جلال الذي هو ابن عمى
وابن قبيلة عبيده وابن وطنه
والذي يعتبر الوحيد في اليمن و الوطن العربي
الذي يمتلك هذه الموهبة دون تعلّم
قام بتصنيع و تصميم وتدريع سيارات
حديثة للجيش اليمني
(تصفيق)
سُميت باسم الاسرة (جلال)
كما هو ظاهر على الشاشة
وبسبب بصمته المميزة الموجودة في سياراته
كانت سبب لمحاولة بعض الدول
استقطاب حسن للعمل عندها
مقابل مزايا مادية ومعنوية كثيره
كالحصول على الجنسية
لكن حبه لوطنه وخدمته لأبناء شعبه
رفض العمل خارج اليمن
(تصفيق)
فحسن بن جلال مثال وطني واحد
من العديد من الأمثلة
الموجودة في عبيده وفي مأرب
وفي عموما اليمن أجمع
الذي يشرفنا كيمنين لنفتخر بهم
في وطننا وخارج وطننا،
(تصفيق)
و أتمني في الأخير أن فاطمة بن جلال
و حسن بن جلال
أن يكون لهم دور في تغيير جزء
من الصورة النمطية السلبية
التي أخذها البعض عن أهل مأرب
وعن قبيلة عبيده.
و الان أترككم للقطة من الفيلم الوثائقي
"أبن القبيلة و التحدي"
سأقول جملة في الأخير
إن الابداع موجود في كل شخص منا
لكن الأهم ان نسخر هذا الابداع
لخدمة وطننا
مهما كان حجمه لا نقلل منه
لان وطننا الان في أمس
الحاجة لكل فرد منا
وشكراً
(تصفيق)